he uh had the win at jack's place now
the number one golfer in the world at
the ripe old age of 25
he's john rum who joins us on the
program john congratulations do you
get anything for being the number one
golfer in the world
uh thank you mr patrick big fan of the
show by the way uh
do i get anything yeah uh well it's uh
it's mission accomplished
that's i think what you get nah there's
no no trophy no
nothing for getting there like like a
chain that has a big number one on it
you don't get that with diamonds on it
it's i mean i would be the first golfer
to have a diamond chain so maybe but i
think i would have to do it myself
you could pass it on to the next guy
let's say if you weren't the number one
player then like you just pass it around
like
there should be some kind of
significance there just being the number
one player
business card i i think i think just the
recognition of being there
and seeing your name at the top of the
ranking is enough for all of us but i
think you're on to something i don't
know if the chain is quite the thing we
need but i think
i think you're on to something if i told
you a decade ago
you're gonna be the number one golfer in
the world
what would you said so
when i was 15 yeah uh
well i don't know what i would have said
but i would have told you if not i was
going to try
i made that deal with myself at close to
that age 13 14 that i was going to set
myself to be the best player in the
world and
yeah that was about 10 11 years ago so
it's it's amazing that it's paid off
when did you know that you could be
great
i wouldn't say there's been one moment
i've always
been very confident of my abilities but
there's been different stages throughout
my career that just made me believe more
and more that i had the
chance to get there right when i was 15
i won the spanish under 21 championship
by six shots and that was one of the
points where well i'm a little bit ahead
of my age and a couple other things in
spain then i won the
the eisenhower trophy the world
championship breaking jack nicholas's
record and i was like whoa this is you
know now world level
i got the number one amateur in the
world and then the last one was when i
was an amateur in college a junior
in college i finished fifth in the
phoenix open and that was the last straw
to
for me to tell me okay you definitely
have the talent you just need to work
very hard and believe that you can get
there and hopefully someday
someday you do what impact did tiger
have on you growing up
big uh well i mean i grew up in that
tiger era right so i i saw him win
everything and every event and er
and the fashion he did it in so he was a
huge influence i believe
for not only me but a generation close
to my age i mean you have jordan spieth
justin thomas me and xander schaffly
all of us are within a year apart and
even bryson de [ __ ] and we're all
playing really good golf nowadays i
think he started something
and you know all this 90s kids are now
playing really good golf i think he
influenced a lot of us but in my case i
was a little bit more influenced by sevi
and and what he did in europe and as a
spanish player he's
he's kind of my idol so i still try to
take and pick things from everybody
obviously
uh most players your age talk about that
first time they played with tiger
what was that like well the first time i
played with tiger was the singles
on sunday at the ryder cup so
it's not going to get much bigger than
that
and i truly couldn't enjoy it because
it's not like it's an individual event
and i'm focused on my own thing it's
it's a head-to-head matchup i have to
beat tiger
both of us were uh winningless at that
point in the ryder cup
uh i think he i was a 1-2 he was on
three so we both really needed a win and
yeah i wasn't playing my best golf i i
couldn't quite enjoy
watching tiger play as much as i could
just because
i truly just tried not to look and think
about tiger woods in front of me right i
just had to win my match but
uh when i won on 17 making birdie in 17
it's it's up to one of the best moments
of my life
explain to me this bryson de chambeau
thing that you just swing as hard as you
possibly can
john now is that going to catch on i saw
where tony fenow said hey
i just thought why not try to swing
harder here
well i spent quite a bit of time with
tony and he's got that speed
i just don't think he he thinks
he could have it under control but i
think bryson is showing him that that
you could
uh now i'm gonna say i think a lot of us
swing as hard as we can we just don't
have that type of speed
um but i think he's he's on to something
right i mean if if you can have the
advantage to
to hit it farther than anybody else and
still be accurate
obviously you're gonna do it right i
mean if you can if
as a running back you can run faster
than anybody else you're not going to
hold back you're just going to go right
so
even any other sport you can take get a
leg up on the competition you're going
to do it and it's very similar to tiger
when he came out
in 97 he he was hidden in miles past
everybody
and dominated the game of golf it's
tough to do it nowadays but
i mean he's been playing really really
good golf i know he didn't play his best
last week but
he's arguably the best player post kobet
so
it's it's impressive yeah but he's
hitting at 430
and 40 yards john
yeah downhill downwind
but nobody else is hitting it 440 yards
downhill
downwind that's that is true yeah he i
mean when he won he averaged 350 yards
which is unheard of but
crazy again golf is just more than hit
in fr
uh and i think this past week jack
proved it right
you can make golf courses
so difficult or set it up in a way where
it neutralizes distance
it's it's as simple as that i think some
of the tournaments you played before
they weren't as penalized and if you
messed it up with tea and you could take
advantage of those things
not at jack's place in that last week
and most likely not a major championship
golf but
who knows i mean he he's onto something
and and what he's done is impressive
he's
worked he's been working on this for
eight nine months people
only heard about it through the pandemic
and he's been working at it hard and and
to have it under control like he does
it's really impressive it's it's truly a
feat of athleticism and technique that
not many of us thought was you know was
possible but he's
taking the game of golf to a next level
now i do believe maybe at some point the
the government bodies in golf might do
some changes to the equipment just so we
don't see people just hitting it 400
yards and flipping wedges onto the green
i think they're going to change the ball
though john i could see where augusta
goes if you're playing the masters
you're going to play a golf ball that is
by our standards
you want to put nike or you want to put
taylormade or whatever you want to put
on at callaway on there because
you run out of real estate and i would
hate to see augusta
you know tighten the fairways make it a
premium of putting it in play there but
still make it a shot makers course there
what do you think i'm surprised they
haven't done that already
i'm not gonna lie uh jack has been
talking about it for a while i think
tigers mentioned it
as well and when you have the two
greatest legends on this game
mention it i'm surprised the apps i'm
sure they've listened and i believe if
bryson comes into november
and overpowers the golf course they'll
definitely take measures
i also believe you know the last few
years the greens had augusta could have
been a little bit firmer
in the mid-2000s they played really
really firm and the winning score was
never low
so they might go on that route again
who knows what they can do i mean
they're the only golf course that
actually have control over how it's
played
so i don't know i don't know what's
gonna happen i don't know what the
future holds all i all i know is
even if they dial back the drivers and
the golf balls
bryson still has that speed so if he can
somehow manage to keep it under control
he's still going to have that advantage
so who knows what's going to happen
he's the number one golfer in the world
he's john rahm joining us on the program
we were going around the room before the
show started of how many hole-in-ones
you've had in your career
now this is practice in tournaments here
uh fritzy how many do you have for john
how many tournaments he's won all in
ones oh hole in one i'm gonna say he has
two hole in ones two holes in one
mclovin nine all right
seton 12 paulie seven
i'm gonna do six
the first guess is two is the closest uh
i've had three
three hole-in-ones well done fritzy
wasn't even listening to the question
well done there todd
favorite sport other than uh in the
united states so i know you love your
soccer but uh favorite
sport other than golf and soccer oh
i love watching any playoffs but
recently i've got on the fight game
i do really love the ufc really how
would you do
if i put you in the octagon with bryson
duchambeau
with bryson yeah i don't know uh he'd
probably figure out a scientific
way to knock me out pretty quick okay
how about kepca
i'm not a fighter i don't know uh i i
i don't know i really have no idea how
any of us would measure i think
i i can't tell you i might have a chance
with anybody out there but i have no
idea when's the last time you were in a
fight
last time i was in a fight yeah like
fist fight yeah
oh must have been i gotta think of the
grades in spanish now
i mean for sure before high school
uh i would say maybe elementary school
that might be the last time
how did it work out i don't remember
i don't think it was a very long fight
uh
when did you start learning english when
you were living in in spain
is it taught in in school yeah yeah yeah
it started school from first to 12th
grade but
the english education system in spain is
not the best i would say
uh pretty much i think starting on fifth
or sixth grade every single year you go
to the first day of class and it's the
exact same thing
present simple next year present simple
next year present simple so
i had to go to extra curricular english
classes
like an english academy to get a little
bit better and even that wasn't enough
to prepare me for the us so i've been
i've been obviously trying to get better
in english knowing that it's important
for golf
for for quite a while but did you learn
english by
listening to music
i didn't learn grammar listening to
music but
uh i learned and i'm assuming you
referring to hip hop
i learned how to pronounce words and
process
things a little bit faster right being
able to memorize all these fast words it
just helped me out a lot to be able to
continue my train of thought and be able
to pronounce and keep up with the
conversation
so eminem played a little bit of a role
in you
a little bit a little bit like eminem
and kendrick lamar too i probably listen
to most
that's good hey congrats there john and
uh
well done certainly with uh the way it
ended there that when
you were interviewed after that final
round and you learned that they were
gonna
probably have a two-stroke penalty on
you like your reaction
just to see it where you're like what
like nobody told you in the moment
that they're and shouldn't they rule in
the moment though john
if they see something happen then they
rule it there because
you could have played the the rest of
the those holes differently
if it was a little bit closer due to
that two-stroke penalty
yeah i would agree with that had they
known
they were going to give me a two-stroke
penalty they should have
notified me and ryan as soon as they
knew they were going to do it
because when i came into scoring there's
no
argument i can make to to get rid of it
right it's it's too late it doesn't
matter whether you give it to me or not
the outcome
is done so i think for the benefit of
golf
they could have just told us earlier
just so
uh you know i already have it and i
think it would have been a two-stroke
lead going to the last two holes i think
it would have played a little bit
different
i think you could tell ryan was a little
deflated after that chip in and
and forced us to make up into holes
right so
it's difficult on the rules of golf
because it also says
uh you know the penalty should be
visible to the naked eye
not with an hd camera there's been
situations in golf
like that before in the past and it's
complicated but
uh after seeing the video yeah it is a
penalty so i wish i would have addressed
it
a little bit different and even so if
if they're gonna decide to tell me after
a round maybe not have it be in a live
interview
national tv especially after i just
talked about how hard my family went
through
a lot of the time my family went through
and all these things and then they told
me well go sign your car you gain a
two-stroke penalty
by it's it's maybe have the rules
tell me before i do my interviews so i
can go in with a clear mind instead of
just getting shocked
at the moment right but uh again they're
gonna do what they think it's best it's
a con
it's an uncomfortable awkward situation
to go through yeah that was
it it was painful to watch because
you're finding that out in real time and
then you mentioned that you've lost some
people in your family due to
complications with covet i mean that it
was a powerful interview
and it was but it was live so we're
seeing you know usually when you get
together with a press conference you
know
you got time to collect yourself that
was right off the course you just say
goodbye to jack nicklaus you're walking
over and
boom and that was a real moment that was
a real moment
that tough yeah well
it is what it is though it's uh the
rules for golf are very clear
and uh it's it's what it is
even talking about your family though
and how important it
was i mean that that's raw emotion there
too that you lost two people in your
life
close to you and you know true true and
and
for people listening they didn't die
because of covet but
being they're both both older and being
basically quarantined closed down in
nursing homes not being able to see
anybody barely able to talk on the phone
it's it's taxing mentally it takes it
takes a toll on you mentally and
you know it makes me glad to know that
my grandma so my mom's mom the one that
spent the most amount of me besides my
parents growing up and taught me so many
things i have so many good memories with
her
was able to see me and my wife get
married in spain she was also able to
see her
first great grandchild be born because
my brother had his first daughter
three four weeks ago so at the same time
we have a lot of things to be happy
about
so but still you know it shows that the
virus is affecting
all of us i think in more than just one
way it can only it can affect you more
than just
physically right uh the situation is
stuff for a lot of people
a lot of people struggling so just be
mindful that
whatever i accomplished in the day
within a tournament being number one in
the world is secondary to all of those
things
and that's the point i was trying to
make across so yeah i put my heart out
and to get the news of the penalty was
maybe not the best timing but
still with penalty no penalty
i still mean every word i said and my
family is still the most important thing
to me so again like i said
at that point a penalty secondary well
said john
and uh congratulations hope to have you
back and uh thanks for joining us
my pleasure thank you very much that's
uh john rom new number one player in the
world